the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is in jeopardy with Jonathan
Major's guilty verdict so what's the MCU
to do with Kang Jonathan major has been
at the center of the news cycle for some
time now for alarming reasons multiple
allegations of abuse his public
relations team cutting ties with him and
news of him being dropped from various
projects have taken him from a Hollywood
Rising Star to someone who's virtually
Untouchable on December 18th the Marvel
actor was found guilty of harassment and
assault in the third degree now Disney
has announced that Majors will no longer
star in the Marvel Cinematic Universe we
just
crossed the threshold no other
background details have been announced
as of the making of this video but The
Hollywood Reporter noted that Marvel
Studios will still be moving forward
with the upcoming Avengers the King
Dynasty film in November 2023 Marvel
veteran writer Michael Waldren who
worked on two seasons of Loki and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
came aboard the film suggesting that a
recast and rethinking of the film's plot
has been in the works for some time
majors made his debut as a Kang variant
known as he who remains on the Disney
plus series Loki he returned to the MCU
in Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
portraying a more vicious version of
Kang that rules the quantum realm in the
Ant-Man film storyline he plays several
other Kang variants such as ramut and am
mortis naturally many have already begun
to ask the big question where does
Marvel Studios go from here with the
Kang character throughout the MC 's
phase 4 and Phase 5 fans have gotten
well acquainted with the Multiverse
various forms of Kang have been depicted
as masters of the Multiverse capable of
traversing it bending it to their will
and working together to take out anyone
against them this is why he and his
variants have been positioned as the
Thanos Level Threats of the Multiverse
Saga which encompasses phases four five
and six though the folks at Marvel
Studios likely could find a way to write
Kang out of the franchise in favor of
another overarching villain it arguably
wouldn't be the right move f know about
the Jonathan major situation and
remember how hard Kang was publicly
pushed as the mcu's next big bad all of
that information would Loom large over
an abruptly kingree MCU likely to the
detriment of the franchise since the
character seems so essential to the
mcu's immediate future it looks like
there's only one viable Way Forward
recast Kang on paper recasting Kang
might seem like a bad idea he's a major
antagonist who has shown his face
multiple times in the MCU so how could
Marvel Studios bring the character back
with a new actor well in terms of the
current multiversal story it makes sense
for Kang variants to have different
faces for instance just look at
Spider-Man no way home where Tom Holland
Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield all
played different versions of Peter
Parker some different kangs even appear
in quantam mania's brief post credit
scene yes variants can have differing
faces in the MCU but there's behind the
scenes precedent too since the earliest
days of the MCU actors have been swapped
out in favor of new ones one of the most
notable examples being Don cheel taking
over for parents Howard as James War
Machine Rose next time baby look it's me
I'm here deal with it then there's Mark
Ruffalo becoming Hulk following Edward
Norton's departure and Katherine Newton
replacing Emma Ferman as Cassie Lang
even Thanos went from Damen patier to
Josh Brolin proving there's no role too
big to recast in the MCU regardless
there are so many ways Marvel Studios
could handle the future of King the
Conqueror in the MCU given how
meticulous Marvel Studios head Kevin
feige is with everything though it
stands to reason he and his team already
have a multiversal plan in the
works